good morning John thank you for your
wonderful video on how to make a baby so
last week I told you how to make a
website in four minutes this week I
discovered something scary internet if
it were a country would have the fifth
largest carbon footprint of all
countries and for us I feel like we're
kind of dual citizens we are citizens of
the USA and of the Internet and being in
the top five twice is just troublesome
so in that spirit on this Wednesday of
how to week I'm gonna talk about how to
be green and not be a prick about it
over to the wall like I said that like
the wall it's a thing that I do
sometimes no I don't so behind me right
now is a pretty amazing thing it's a
thing that was made by a guy named David
and if you want to know more about then
you should check down here end up in the
pants area down here it's called the
breathing earth it is a graphical
representation of what is going on in
the earth was kind of a focus on the
environment every time you see a little
blue star pop up that means that someone
in that country just got born and every
time you see a little black pop up that
means that someone in that country just
died and every time country flashes red
that means that that country just
emitted a thousand tons of carbon
dioxide and you'll notice that since we
started india's little flashing a kid is
getting born thing has not stopped
blinking it blinks all the time also
since we started China and the USA have
been blinking red quite rapidly which is
fairly frightening it's all in real-time
so there is actually a baby popping out
of a mother every time you see a little
white star now the reason I love this
thing is because it helps me understand
it helps me understand the beauty and
the awesome power of humanity it helps
me to take something that is by and
large
impossible to understand and understand
it that we are able to keep that many
people alive many of them happily alive
it's really amazing and it's also very
inspiring of course it also points out a
lot of the problems that we have and
understanding these problems is the only
way to help the environment now a lot of
people if you clicked on this video and
you don't know who I am you probably
expect me to tell you a list of things
that you can do or a list of things that
you can buy I could stand here and tell
you the importance of wearing sweaters
indoors in winter and tell you how much
you really shouldn't drive so much go
buy efficient appliances and sign up for
green power generation with your power
company all these things are important
but all these things only help your
impact and as long as you're doing this
because you're trying to alleviate your
purse
impact your personal guilt about how you
feel about the environment that's never
gonna help anybody
the solution is understanding if you
don't understand the world then there is
nothing you can change besides yourself
and as important as changing yourself is
as you can see from this graphic China
is flashing faster than the United
States changing ourselves is not going
to solve this problem real solutions
don't get created without real
understanding this is a dramatically
complicated problem so if you asked me
to tell you how to be green without
being a prick the only way to do it is
to understand understand that you cannot
stop a guy from burning down a forest if
it's going to help him feed his children
understand that you as a citizen of the
developed world have far more wealth and
happiness and power than the vast
majority of people in the world
understand that every single star on the
map behind me is a child being born and
to someone that child is just as
precious as your child is understand
that there is not enough land on the
earth by a long shot
for everyone to eat the way that
Americans eat and once you understand
these problems once you understand the
actual complexity of this situation then
you can start to understand the
solutions because the real secret to
being green is being educated and
empowered enough not only to make good
decisions for yourself but also to help
create the solutions that will allow the
people of this world to prosper without
destroying the natural systems that they
rely upon and that is not easy that is a
long and complicated process but we have
to do it because without being dedicated
and smart and informed we are going to
kill ourselves and I am not kidding
about that John I will see you on Friday
and my phone's ringing so I'm gonna
answer it hello